[Musique]
un an tout rond après la pause de la
première pierre l'infrastructure de la
chambre rit a été inaugurée une odeur de
neuf flotte dans les 1200 mètres carrés
sortis de terre en un temps record et la
très attendue salle de sport haut de
gamme a été installé on a eu beaucoup
beaucoup de
charges à soulever pour pouvoir
installer cette salle de musculation il
faut savoir qu'elle était entreposée à
la base aérienne de tours pendant
plusieurs mois et on l'a donc déménagé
il y a déjà deux trois semaines rameur
vélo et même piste de vitesse les
membres de l'US to rugby ont ainsi déjà
pris possession du matériel les 3,2
millions d'euros investis étaient
nécessaires pour redonner du souffle au
parc sportif touranjo si on est sur le
site d'entraînement de l'ESTO rugby on
va on livre un outil exceptionnel qui
permet à la fois d'accueillir du sport
loisir mais aussi du sport compétition
et on a un des outils exceptionnels qui
va permettre de qui permet de replacer
le tour parmi les villes les plus
sportives de France accueillir des
compétitions lui est-ce rugby ou encore
l'équipe de football américain l'après
coupe du monde de rugby est déjà sur les
rails les sont d'abord le temps aux
Irlandais de s'y installer